goldsmith little Anya is well-known in
Belsen and elsewhere his handmade
creations sell as far away as
Switzerland and Canada do skip one I was
born here and I've worked here for the
last 25 years I moved into this house in
1994 with my workshop the city used to
be gray and shabby I'm going to show you
three of my favorite places so that you
can see what has become of this town of
the organism long as jewelry sharp looks
more like an art gallery in rooms dating
back to the 14th century
he presents selected works made from
gold silver and platinum just a few
paces away is the marketplace the first
port of call for tourists from all
around the world
lota lana leads us through the nikolai
gate or nicolas gate one of Belson's
historic town gates we're on our way to
the Church of st. Nicholas a ruin that
dates back to the 15th century
so this is the santa calluses graveyard
in bouncing it's one of my favorite
places because there's something
mystical about it it's a smaller Marsh
to the artist Caspar David Friedrich
it's good for the soul to be here the
ruins might have inspired great German
Romantic painter Caspar David Friedrich
he lived for a while in nearby dresden
cosmo target it said Caspar David
Friedrich first practiced his painting
and art here it might be a rumor but it
could be true most people in belts and
have some kind of connection to this
place that's what makes this place so
special for Lana from st. Nicholas you
can also see the old trade route via
regia or rural highway which brought
prosperity to the town in the Middle
Ages his next tip is around Rotenberg
it's about ten minutes on foot from the
centre
youth and by WB here's another of my
favorite places behind me a view of
bouncing I think it's complex history
and the way it's been preserved is quite
unique in Germany everyone who sees it
locals or tourists is bound to find it
attractive the view changes as you
continue along the route
it's certainly apparent from here why
Belson is called the town of towers
langa often came here as a child because
his school was closed to the Protestant
back for his next recommendation we need
to return to the old town if you're
tired after taking in all the sights
I'll take you to the Goliath cafe with
its freshly baked cake and live music
and Hank I'm optimistic Goliath is run
by Martin Mitchell and manned even sure
he's a passionate musician and she is
Apache seer while Martin looks after the
guests Mandi focuses on her tarts and
cakes
the pair opened the cafe in 2013 and it
took off after all the two of them
really have lots to offer their
customers including musical interludes
their wine and coffee shop was a
personal dream come true and it is also
a breath of fresh air in bouts ins old
quarter